[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
mitri sirin schönen guten abend ihnen
allen alles wieder auf null zumindest in
der fußball-bundesliga christina dann
geht's wieder los 50 spieltage bis zur
wm guten abend und das sind die themen
an diesem freitag
china gegen die usa wegen der taiwan
krise friert peking die zusammenarbeit
bei klima- und verteidigung ein
washington reagiert
ein weg aus der gaskrise pipeline für
flüssiggas aus wilhelmshaven wird im
rekordtempo gebaut
und großfeuer in berlin teilweise unter
kontrolle die explosionsgefahr am
sprengplatz ist aber noch nicht gebannt
das chinesische echo auf den taiwan
besucht der us
spitzenpolitikerin pelosi mündet nicht
nur in einem massiven militärmanöver
rund um taiwan auch diplomatische
geschütze werden jetzt aufgefahren
peking stoppt die zusammenarbeit mit den
usa etwa in klima und
verteidigungsfragen außerdem wurden
sanktionen gegen pelosi und ihre familie
beschlossen aus washington el mati
wissen
es soll die menschen in taiwan bull
einschüchtern chinesische kampfjets
einmal mehr innerhalb der schutzzone um
die insel den militärischen drohungen
folgen jetzt die politischen die
gespräche mit den usa zum kampf gegen
den klimawandel
pandemien und drogen handel ausgesetzt
antwort auf die kritik der us-regierung
an den chinesischen militärübungen die
maßnahmen chinas sind entschlossen
kraftvoll und angemessen die manöver
offen transparent und professionell sie
halten sich an nationale und
internationale gesetze
doch einige der raketen die china in den
vergangenen tagen abfeuerte landeten
auch in einer wirtschaftszone des
nahegelegenen japan die chinesische
volksbefreiungsarmee behauptet nur ziele
rund um zwei wochen getroffen zu haben
beim treffen der asian starten in
kambodscha war die stimmung angespannt
zum ende der konferenz erneuerte
us-außenminister blinken seine kritik an
peking
der besuch von pelosi war friedlich es
gibt keine rechtfertigung für diese
extreme unverhältnismäßige und escala
torische militärische antwort
in tokio machte nancy pelosi heute klar
wie wichtig den usa die zusammenarbeit
mit china ist
wir müssen mit china in der klimakrise
zusammenarbeiten weil hier die zwei
größten verschmutzer sind und wir können
dabei viel von china lernen
sich der us regierung schadet sich china
selbst mit dem stopp der gespräche den
gemeinsamen kampf gegen globale gefahren
auf eis zu legen wegen einer politiker
reise das könnte im rest der welt
unverständnis auslösen das us
außenministerium hat jetzt den
chinesischen botschafter einbestellt um
diese sicht zu vermitteln
gehen wir nach peking zu ulf röller ulf
also aus protest gegen den besuch von
piloten stoppt man die zusammenarbeit
mit den usa was hat peking vor
ich glaube es geht erstmal chipping dem
chinesischen präsidenten darum stärke zu
zeigen bei seinen eigenen leuten bei der
heimatfront denn dies ist ein sehr
schwieriges jahr für den chinesischen
präsidenten die wirtschaft läuft
überhaupt nicht gut und der hauptgrund
ist eben die 0 kokot strategie von jp
legt das land lahm und da gibt es schon
sehr viel unmut und nun kommt dieser
besuch quasi der den präsidenten schwach
aussehen lässt man muss wissen shipping
hat ganz klar vorhergesagt dass seit
wäre eine überschreitung einer roten
linie der amerikaner die amerikaner am
das relativ selbstbewusst getan und nun
sieht er schwach im eigenen land aus und
wird sehr stark eben auch intern von den
nationalisten im land kritisiert ich
glaube was shipping jetzt mit den
anderen drohgebärden erreichen wird ist
dass es quasi nicht eine permanente
besuchs diplomatie nach taiwan gibt und
deshalb tritt er so massiv aus ich
glaube nicht dass er ein militärische
konflikt sucht dafür hält er sich nicht
stark genug aber alles unterhalb dieser
grenze wird er dann doch auffahren um
sehr deutlich zu machen dass er keine
weiteren besucher will es ist also eben
dieses armdrücken zwischen der weltmacht
amerika und der weltmacht china und noch
ist nicht klar wie das ausgeht aber 1
doch sicher das internationale klima
wird sehr frostig wohl vielen dank für
die einschätzung nach peking und jetzt
direkt zum anderen großkonflikt türkei
staatschef erdogan hat den ukraine krieg
auch für sich nutzen können
innenpolitisch unter druck hat er sich
schon früh in eine mittlerrolle begeben
zwischen russland und der ukraine
er handelte erfolgreich den getreide
deal mit aus und verfolgt dabei auch
eigene interessen etwa gegen die kurden
in nordsyrien vorzugehen wofür aber die
zustimmung moskaus bräuchte heute trafen
sich erdogan und russlands präsident
putin im russischen sotchi lukb ipod
betont freundlich empfing präsident
putin seinen türkischen amtskollegen
erdogan er lobte dessen
vermittlungsbemühungen beim
zustandekommen des getreide abkommens
dank ihrer beteiligung und der vereinten
nationen konnte das problem der
ukrainischen weizen ausfuhren gelöst
werden dafür möchte ich ihnen persönlich
danken
am morgen waren drei weitere
getreidefrachter mit mehr als 50.000
tonnen futtermais an bord aus
ukrainischen helfen richtung bosporus
ausgelaufen beim gespräch zwischen putin
und erdogan ging es neben der ukraine
auch um bilateralen handel und russische
energielieferungen die russische firma
saturn baut derzeit am mittelmeer das
erste türkische kernkraftwerk das
nächstes jahr ans netz gehen soll putin
betonte russische gaslieferungen in die
türkei über die touchscreen leitung
liefen in vollen umfang weiter ein
zynischer hinweis darauf dass das nato
land türkei dass die westlichen
sanktionen gegen russland nicht
unterstützt besser dastehe als andere
die europäer sollten der türkei dankbar
sein dass die türkei eine gasversorgung
überzog stream möglich macht
präsident erdogan forderte erneut
russlands unterstützung für seine
geplante militäroffensive gegen
kurdische milizen in nordsyrien
solidarität im kampf gegen den
terrorismus ist sehr wichtig wir hoffen
bei diesem treffen hier fortschritte in
der frage zu erzielen
die türkei unterstützt den syrien die
islamistische opposition russland
hingegen den machthaber assad im vorfeld
des treffens hatte sich moskau
zurückhaltend zu erdogans forderungen
geäußert
bei luftangriffen der israelischen armee
auf den gazastreifen ist ein
hochrangiger befehlshaber der
palästinenserorganisation islamischer
dschihad getötet worden laut
israelischem militär soll ein angriff
aus gaza unmittelbar bevor gestanden
haben insgesamt kamen palästinensischen
angaben zufolge mindestens acht menschen
ums leben mindestens 40 sollen verletzt
worden sein der islamische dschihad
kündigte vergeltungsmaßnahmen an
jetzt in den irak dort sind
hunderttausende menschen dem aufruf des
schiiten führers als hatte zu einem
massengebet gefolgt und versammelt sich
dann in bagdad im regierungsviertel
dieses freitagsgebet ist die jüngste
machtdemonstration als sah dies nachdem
seine anhänger zuletzt schon zweimal das
parlament stürmten er will die auflösung
des parlaments und vorgezogene neuwahlen
erreichen bei den vergangenen wahlen
hatte seine partei die meisten stimmen
erhalten konnte aber keine regierung
bilden
die gasspeicher in deutschland sind
erstmals seit beginn des ukraine krieges
wieder zu über 70 prozent gefüllt und
doch stellt sich die frage ob das
reichen wird und wie das in zukunft
wieder günstiger werden kann ein
baustein hierfür ist lng also
verflüssigtes erdgas das mit tankern
über das mittelmeer kommt in
wilhelmshaven soll noch in diesem jahr
das erste von mehreren schwimmenden
terminals entstehen aber von dort fehlen
rund 26 kilometer pipeline bis zum
einspeisepunkt in das gasnetz die sollen
jetzt im rekordtempo gebaut werden mehr
von elisabeth schmitt
1500 dieser stahlrohre jedes neuen
tonnenschwer sollen im dezember schon in
der erde liegen normalerweise dauert so
ein gaspipeline-projekt bis zu acht
jahre jetzt muss es in zehn monaten
gehen
dadurch dass die genehmigung massiv
beschleunigt werden beispielsweise den
netzentwicklungsplan der am anfang eines
jeden projektes in deutschland steht
dauert zwei jahre
es hat hier das
bundeswirtschaftsministerium zusammen
mit der bundesnetzagentur durch
entsprechende verschriftlichung in zwei
wochen gelöst zurzeit wird die baustraße
für die gut 26 kilometer lange
gasleitung aufgeschüttet 130 parteien
eigentümer und landwirte mussten
zustimmen einige bekommen hohe
entschädigungszahlungen läuft alles nach
plan werden tanke ab dem 22 dezember
flüssigerdgas zum schwimmenden terminal
nach wilhelmshaven bringen allein über
diesen einen allen die anleger könnten
pro jahr 20 prozent der russischen
erdgaslieferungen ersetzt werden es
hätte schon viel früher so weit sein
können
haben uns lange ausgeruht und wir haben
2009 10 dieses projekt zumal geplant und
es ist damals auch am widerstand in der
region gescheitert weil der eindruck war
wieso wir haben doch das russische gas
obwohl wir die annektierung der krim
hatten obwohl wir hätten viel schlauer
sein müssen in der frage sind wir nicht
zu abhängig widerstand gibt es auch
jetzt von umweltverbänden doch er ist
leiser geworden sie kritisieren vor
allem dass sie im zuge des eilig
verabschiedeten lng
beschleunigungsgesetz es kaum zeit für
widerspruch hatten
da entstehen also schon schallpegel die
die meeresumwelt schädigen besonders
haben wir im auge hier den schweinswal
streng geschützte art doch in zeiten des
gas streits mit russland geht die
versorgungssicherheit vor in
wilhelmshaven stehen alle zeichen auf
bauen im turbotempo
das flüssiggas kommt via tanker
natürlich nicht über das mittelmeer
sondern über die nordsee pardon dafür
vorsichtiges aufatmen bei flugreisenden
die lufthansa hat sich im tarifkonflikt
mit dem bodenpersonal auf eine deutliche
lohnerhöhung geeinigt mit dem verdi
abschluss sind weitere streiks zumindest
des bodenpersonals erst einmal
abgewendet für die rund 20.000
beschäftigten gibt es in mehreren
schritten mindestens 325 euro mehr im
monat zusätzlich eine pauschale
gehaltserhöhung von 2,5 prozent und der
mindestlohn steigt auf 13 euro pro
stunde im tarifkonflikt mit den piloten
gibt es noch keine einigung
monatelang hat die korona pandemie
millionen schülern einiges abverlangt
kaum präsenzunterricht mehr oder weniger
gelungene online kurse und die folge
wissenslücken bei vielen kindern und
jugendlichen auch in diesem sommer
sollen spezielle lerncamps defizite
abbauen helfen aus sachsen anhalt
berichtet jetzt hagen nicolas in fünf
tagen etwas von dem nachholen was
während des online unterrichts verpasst
wurde dafür sind die schüler der fünften
und sechsten klasse hier im lärm camp in
naumburg in sachsen anhalt bei vielen
der kinder ist die angst groß versäumte
inhalte zu verschleppen dadurch dass ich
da nicht mitgemacht habt kamen die
lücken die wurden dann immer größer und
dadurch hatte ich halt auch nie mehr so
richtig so motivation zu lernen weil ich
dachte ich komme mir nicht mehr weiter
meine noten in englisch habe waren auch
nicht so gut und meine mutter meinte
oder hatte oder fand halt besser wenn
ich hier bin dass ich hier halt noch mal
in den ferien auf bisschen was
dazulernen
da sich dann in der siebten klasse
richtig gas geben kann und nicht fast
sitzen bleibe dagegen setzt sachsen
anhalt 26 fächer spezifische lerncamps
täglich vier stunden mathe deutsch
biologie oder englisch sollen defizite
zumindest verringern genauso wie
gemeinsame freizeit am nachmittag das
ist natürlich eine woche zu kurz aber es
kann natürlich einen kleinen beitrag
leisten um vor allem schüler zu
motivieren zu lernen auch eine aktuelle
bundesweite studie der berliner humboldt
universität sieht bei viertklässlern bis
zu sechs monate bildungsrückstand
zusatzangebote wie dieses seien ein
guter schritt doch um lern rückstände
nachhaltig abzubauen brauche es mehr so
bildungsexperten wenn lerncamps gut
gemacht sind dann ermöglichen sie einen
sogenannten flying start das heißt dass
die lernenden besonders motiviert
besonders engagiert und auch besonders
gut vorbereitet in das neue schuljahr
starten dann muss es aber weitergehen
das heißt wir brauchen konzepte zur
individuellen förderung die im schuljahr
auch tragen auch das campen buch
verbindet lernstoff und gemeinschaft für
die 17 kinder hier ein schritt zu lang
vermissten normalität
sie wissen
selbstverständlichkeiten werden gerade
in einem atemberaubenden tempo in frage
gestellt und dazu gehört auch die
ständige verfügbarkeit von wasser eine
unserer wichtigsten ressourcen und das
nicht nur bei uns in 45 prozent der
regionen in der eu gab es im juli eine
dürre warnung hier in orange dargestellt
auch in weiten teilen der niederlande
wie unsere nachbarn damit umgehen jetzt
florian hahn dazu in nimwegen in den
niederlanden sind es zum beispiel die
bewohner dieser hausboote die dürre
ziemlich konkret spüren weil ein teil
ihrer wohnung nun auf grund liegt
einige sind sogar ausgezogen weil ihre
boote wirklich gekippt sind sie konnten
also nicht mehr normal laufen
seit wochen hat es nicht ausreichend
geregnet manche kanäle sind für den
schiffsverkehr bereits gesperrt die
regierung hat offiziell den
wassernotstand ausgerufen konkret heißt
das dass wir nun auf der nationalen
ebene entscheiden wie wir das wasser
verteilen so dürfen landwirte
mancherorts nicht mehr so stark
bewässern die bisher die versorgung mit
trinkwasser ist derzeit nicht betroffen
aufgerufen wasser zu sparen aber sind
alle zumal keine besserung in sicht ist
die augen drauf ist eine trockenheit die
für den august eigentlich nicht üblich
ist es ist aber nicht das erste jahr wir
hatten so eine dürre schon 2018 2019 und
2020 das hat bereits spuren hinterlassen
denn dort herrschen spore 80er
wassermangel ein phänomen das weite
teile europas betrifft immer wichtiger
wird daher abwasser zu klären und
wiederzuverwenden meint auch die eu
kommission die dazu neue leitlinien
veröffentlicht das extreme prozent es
ist sehr wichtig dass wir wasser
verantwortungsbewussten nutzen und dass
wir dabei auch die
gesundheitsvorschriften einheiten
compliance auditing
standards wie wichtig wasser ist merken
sie in den niederlanden derweil auch bei
ihren teichen die den teil des landes
schützen der unterhalb des
meeresspiegels liegt durch die
trockenheit drohen die deiche instabil
zu werden ihre versorgung daher eine
frage der sicherheit
leichte entspannung gibt es im berliner
grunewald ein teil des feuers dort ist
gelöscht allerdings ist die
explosionsgefahr rund um den sprengplatz
weiter hoch zwei weltkriegsbomben
gefährden die arbeit der einsatzkräfte
unklar ist noch immer warum das feuer
ausbrach markus gross
ein bisschen regen heute morgen aber
keine entscheidende hilfe für die
berliner feuerwehr
kilometerlange schlauchleitungen viele
flammen bereits gelöscht die
brandbekämpfer seit über 38 stunden im
einsatz am vormittag konnten sie sich
den brennenden sprengplatz immer weiter
nähern auch dank ferngesteuerter roboter
und gepanzerte fahrzeuge die zum löschen
und erkunden eingesetzt wurden so dass
wir an dieser stelle schon sagen können
sind wir etwas entspannter als gestern
zumal auch wenn sich das wetter so
darstellt wie jetzt im augenblick die
auch mit einer verschärfung der lage
nicht zu rechnen haben immer noch kleine
brandnester wie diese aktuellen
luftaufnahmen zeigen aber kein vergleich
zu den bildern von gestern mehrere
heftige detonationen große feuerstellen
die den boden auf bis zu 700 grad
erhitzt haben löscharbeiten dort nicht
möglich weil gelagerte fliegerbomben aus
ihren verankerungen gerissen wurden sie
werden derzeit von den lösch robotern
gekühlt liegen aber ungesichert auf dem
gelände es geht um zwei kampfmittel die
da hinausgeworfen wurden zwei
weltkriegsbomben da geht es
hauptsächlich eine entsprechend geringe
temperatur zu erreichen um sich die ihn
auch über den bereich auch wieder
annähern zu können erst wenn diese
gefahren gebannt sind kann der
sperrkreis entsprechend verringert
werden die angrenzende autobahn und
bahnlinie bleiben vorerst gesperrt noch
unklar wann hier wieder der verkehr
rollen kann
so die zeit der vorbereitung die ist
vorbei in gut einer stunde an für
christen da wollen die bayern schon mal
vorlegen im top spiel gibt es dann am
samstag also morgen abend das duell der
letztjährigen bayern-verfolger der
zweite empfängt den dritten borussia
dortmund bayer leverkusen
beflügelt vom heimvorteil ausverkauft
will der bvb ein erstes zeichen setzen
erstmals als chefcoach vor einer solchen
kulisse dortmunds edin terzic mit
rückenwind nach auswärtige pokal bei
1860 münchen es war ein sehr guter start
in die saison wir haben sehr erwachsen
und sehr sehr reif verteidigt und
entschlossen deshalb haben sie ja einen
nico schlotterbeck aus freiburg geholt
sein partner in der innenverteidigung
niklas süle allerdings fehlt verletzt
wird durch hummels ersetzt im sturm wird
die verantwortung verteilt holland
nachfolger alea wird durch seine
erkrankung länger ausfallen ganz anders
die stimmung bei leverkusen nach der
pokalpleite jetzt war es erste fritsch
bewusst um was ging und wir haben's
vergeigt wären es verkackt da ist 34
beim drittligisten elversberg hat den
spielern einige tage die laune verdorben
doch ich spüre da beim team die lust und
der wille sofort eine steigerung einen
tag zu legen das letzte spiel in
dortmund ein stimmungs booster
leverkusen gewann im februar mit 5 zu 2
und alles zum topspiel und der bund dem
bundesliga auftakt morgen abend im
aktuellen sportstudio
hindernisläuferin gesa felicitas krause
hat krankheitsbedingt die open
championships in münchen abgesagt
kommenden donnerstag geht es los in
neuen sportarten viele stars sind dabei
so auch das aushängeschild der deutschen
leichtathletik ihre mission gold geht
weiter weltmeisterin melanie hahn
betritt in münchen an ob auch ihren em
titel zu verteidigen sie ist die größte
deutsche medaillenhoffnung der
leichtathletik die 4 x 100 meter staffel
der frauen um china lückenkemper mit
wm-bronze geschmückt will auch bei der
em unter die ersten drei im turnen ist
lukas fauser als tokio
silbermedaillengewinner am barren und
deutscher mehrkampfmeister ein kandidat
für eine medaille
hoch hinaus natürlich aufs treppchen
will auch der aktuelle kletter
weltmeister in der kombination und
weltcupsieger im bouldern jannik fliehen
insgesamt gibt es 177 medaillen
entscheidungen in münchen
und ihr übertragen live viel sendezeit
dankeschön christin ob es noch badesee
tauglich bleibt gleich im wetter mit
christa orden diesen nachrichten tag
ordnet später christian sievers nochmal
ab 22 uhr im heute journal ein vielen
dank fürs zuschauern vom gesamten heute
19 team und kommen sie gut ins
wochenende
[Musik]
guten abend das satellitenbild von heute
mittag zeigt uns die wolken der
kaltfront ihr quer über dem land die
sorgte heute in cuxhaven nur noch für
höchstwerte von 19 grad vor der
kaltfront da war es allerdings noch mal
richtig heiß mit 36 grad in regensburg
und in dieser heißen südosthälfte da
gibt es aktuell schon seit dem
nachmittag teils kräftige gewitter und
das geht heute abend und in der nacht
dann auch so weiter von berlin
brandenburg bis an die alpen schauer und
gewitter die größte unwettergefahr die
besteht allerdings im donau umfeld und
südlich davon damit wieder hagel und
schwere sturmböen
aber starkregen es auch wieder mit dabei
teilweise über mehrere stunden also
vorsicht hier vor überflutungen der
temperaturunterschied ist auch in der
nacht noch da es kühlt ab auf 8 grad bei
klarem himmel auf 18 grad nur in der
gewitter luft morgen ist der unterschied
dann nicht mehr so deutlich zu spüren da
haben wir 19 grad an den küsten und
angenehmere 27 grad am rhein dazu
beruhigt sich das wetter auch südlich
der donau ist es stark bewölkt
vereinzelt gibt es dann noch mal ein
schauer und ein gewitter sonst viel
sonne und nur lockere folgen die
nächsten tage sind von hochdruckeinfluss
geprägt also viel sonne wenig wolken es
fällt kaum noch mal ein tropfen regen im
handy temperaturen sind angenehm bei 20
bis 32 grad